dans le loir-et-cher juliette la
photographe yu buzz a rendez vous avec
l'art l'histoire et avec mère nature
un programme royal en somme j'arrive au
château de chaumont-sur-loire qui datent
du 10ème siècle mais qui a su se
renouveler puisque la nature
environnante
aujourd'hui accueil d'état d'oeuvres
d'art contemporain alors j'ai
rendez-vous et chantal qui est la
directrice du lieu qui va le faire
découvrir tout ça apparemment il ya
aussi un festival des jardins
j'ai hâte d'en savoir plus chantal c'est
la directrice du château
son credo mettre l'art contemporain au
coeur de ces jardins pour le rendre
accessible à tous bonjour jean talon
jour julia atta bienvenue à sur moi sans
loi le merci beaucoup
alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous en
dire plus sur cet endroit qui a l'air
formidable h en décembre c'est un lieu
très complexe
c'est à la fois un château renaissance
sur la loi et puis c'est aussi un centre
d'art contemporain comme le montre cette
magnifique oeuvre 12 des penan qui nous
accueille et c'est aussi le lieu du
festival international des jardins qui
est très réputé vous cette vie là bas
c'est un festival qui existe depuis 29
ans et qui montrent chaque année de 30
nouveaux jardins c'est considéré comme
un observatoire des tendances jardin
laboratoire du lait quand je t'ai de
piocher quelques idées qui sait oui
enfin c'est autre chose qu'un potager en
fond court 1 chaumont je vous propose
que nous allions du côté des jardins et
donc on va aller vers le festival
jardins et baï plaisir je vous suis
le festival dure six mois chaque année
une thématique différente permettent à
30 concepteurs et jardiniers d'investir
les lieux d'ailleurs le thème de cette
année c'est le retour à la terre mère
nous sommes ici dans un jardin qui
s'appelait la régénération et qui
illustrent très clairement cette théorie
de l'effondrement dont on parle beaucoup
mais on voit et on verra que les
derniers arbres repousse et il me semble
que cet effondrement et ses espoirs
végétaux on dise plus que parfois
certains discours scientifique ou
discours politique qui rentrent moins
bien dans la tête des gens et d'ailleurs
si on passe dans l'autre sens on peut
avoir l'impression qu'effectivement le
la situation s'améliore absolument oui
c'est une vision positive de ce jardin
et il y en a pour tous les goûts
alors où est ce que vous emmenez
maintenant chantal en chemin dans un
jardin punk c'est à dire qu'on peut
avoir jardin très très différent de
celui dont on a l'habitude et j'imagine
quelque chose d'un peu de déstructurer
regarder l'entrée en fait qu'est-ce
qu'on a d'habitude on a des parpaings
dans nos villes très laide et vous
verrez que en fait l'idée de préserver
la nature et de travailler avec les
éléments de la nature laisser la nature
suivre son rythme récupérer les pierres
récupérer le bois punch est magnifique
en même temps c'est pas commun la
journée s'annonce pleine de surprises
[Musique]